the Joe Rogan experience what why an
accordion like what is are you a monkey
no the guy who has the accordion the
monkey dance the monkey dances and I
love the sound of the accordion and I
just I saw it and I just wanted to bring
something to the new studio I like how
you have a lot of weird [ __ ] here and
this is weird that somebody loved this
sound so much that they decided let's
make an instrument out of it yeah are
they're like real complicated ones of
those like do people play them and
orchestras and [ __ ] no I don't think
they made it into the orchestra so it's
never been like a really respected piece
of musical instrument design OCO New
Orleans buckwheat zydeco you hear that
sure Zamfir master of the pan flute of
course what happened in that poor
bastard like he had a whole marketing
team behind they like dude no one's done
this we're gonna do this master the pan
flute DVD CDs VHS tapes we're gonna sell
it all there's literally no competition
there's nothing you can do the year
Zamfir
he's the Tony Hawk of the he looks like
a guy that works in the deli
that is a very forgettable sound it's a
recorder it's for like when the one
things you learn when you're in fourth
grade and they teach you music yeah I
never I never paid attention to the
recorder because they gave me the
recorder and I go well what how come I
don't see this in bands yeah the [ __ ]
out of here I'm not gonna spend some
time learning an instrument that no one
plays you had to need to carry it in
your sock they didn't even have cases
just give me yeah get old tube sock from
your dad and put it in there that's
right
makes a case for the [ __ ] recorder no
yet to put in your dad's sock and it
didn't make any sense either that it was
oh he's got it but he plays a flute
right well it said pan flute when I
talked to Dan but oh well he's a bad
[ __ ]
yeah Jethro Tull's he's going crazy
looking dude he looks like he lives in a
hollowed-out tree oh my god
scary when you walk by on the trail
hello has anybody else figured out how
to use the flute in rock and roll music
besides jethro tull uh it's been some
flute there's been but not like him
right now where it's now it's hard of a
lead like a band will come along and
they'll just figure out how to do
something and no one's figured out yeah
yeah exactly
no we're gonna do this yeah we're just
gonna throw flute in the mix should we
get a flute I was uh I was doing this
show last weekend and this guy had an
oboe he was like the the in San
Francisco he's one of the like the
oboist
in the world he's playing this
instruments very melancholy it's
beautiful but it really was occurring to
me like why who built this who thought
this sound was so important when they
decided we're gonna make an instrument
so we can recreate this feeling and this
sound for all those instruments in this
what if you gave me a pen and a paper
and told me to draw an oboe I'd be
[ __ ] yeah I it's not what I thought it
was I want to thin and I'm thinking of a
trombone I'm thinking of a thing where
but it's definitely not that way bigger
yes okay pull it up and see what the
oboe is straight oh it looks like a
flute yeah it's straight it looks almost
like a clarinet oh yeah clarinet that's
what I'm thinking not a flute
[Applause]